I think that if a foreigner would come
for the first time to Israel to Tel Aviv
he would find it very close to what he
sees as American life Tel Aviv is the
most vibrant lively peaceful city in in
the Middle East and has nothing to be
ashamed in comparison to London Berlin
or Barcelona and nobody would sense that
there is an ongoing clash between the
Israeli Palestinians just hundred
kilometers away down south or some huge
tension 200 kilometers north Israeli
society is now blooming with the
high-tech industry that brings in US
quantities of money people who who are
veterans
young fresh veterans of Israeli
intelligence technological divisions are
picked up immediately by these high-tech
startups earning huge salaries happy to
live in Israel happy to to to advanced
Israeli high-tech industry to the place
it takes today bringing foreign foreign
investments and basically life are very
good and I think I would give a sad
example of I would take it from a sad
incident but it proves why life are very
good because the economic system they
couldn't the economy is very strong when
failing the the Yom Kippur War of
October of 1973 people went out of the
streets to demonstrate for prime
minister Golda Meir and Minister of
Defense machinery they ant to resign the
economy was in a worse shape people were
demonstrate
in demonstrating and forced them to
resign after Israel failed the 2006 war
against Hezbollah almost nobody went to
the streets not because it was a lesser
horrendous failure but because the
economy was good people are happy they
were not happy to not be reliable to
disassemble his mother but life are good
so and I think that that was a disgrace
I think that it was a major disgrace
that only stayed in power after failing
this war but yet it does prove how
strong the society is and how strong the
economy is you know that chief of staff
with no shame in the first hours of the
war in Lebanon of 2006 when it was not
yet clear to the public that we are
going to war but he mood what's going on
he ordered his broker to sell all of his
stocks because he thought that the that
the stock exchange is going to go down
but not only that he did something
completely immoral while facilitating
the the knowledge that he had but he
with a burst made a mistake because the
stock exchange keep just kept on rising
you